this is an emergency video because open
AI held their first ever developer
conference so this better be something
good right well it is chalk full of
goodies so hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because first this is gp4 Turbo
this is a version of their amazing AI
that can now do three things better and
there is so much more my goodness first
context length has become longer from 8
to 32k to
128,000 4X okay but what does this mean
well this means that we can even cram a
300 page textbook in there and then talk
to the book or add internal company
rules legal information mathematics
video game ideas anything you wish up to
about 300 Pages now it will be able to
handle all these so good two it now
follows instructions better and three we
don't have to rely on random answers
that change every time we ask the same
thing as they just announced seat
parameters for consistent outputs and
plus one knowledge cut off has been
updated from September 2021 to April
2023 so it knows about more recent
things plus a promise that it will never
be so much out of date again and all
these changes are now part of Chad GPT
it is now using GPT 4 Turbo yummy and it
gets better dear fellow Scholars this is
two minute papers with Dr Caro GPT now
speaks in a more natural manner when
voice input came in for me it was an
immediate game Cher it is powered by
Whisper we saw in an earlier episode
that it can easily take a full several
hour long podcast and transcribe it
nearly instantly with minimal errors
close to as good as a human Pro and now
whisper is also on version three and it
got even better wow and check this out
this is actually insane it is now way
better and at the same time it got
cheaper in fact 2 to 3x cheaper than the
regular gp4 that is insane why is that
well we just noted in a previous episode
that it can give you great usability
tips for your already existing product
and it costs about a Cent and it will
cost even less than a cent soon and on
the very day I made that video they
announced that they are making this to
two to three times cheaper that is
insane speed improvements are coming too
however in the meantime we already see
that gp4 turbo is incredibly quick much
quicker than any previous version if
this is supposed to be the slowest
future version of it wow sign me up
right now and there is so much more
coming the annoying model picker is also
gone my early experiments seem to
indicate
that it will lean on its own knowledge
base when it can and it only browses the
internet for no information when
necessary great Improvement and now it
is time time for the other bumb shell
feature which is not some new GPT but
gpts yes that's right gpts now you can
build your own chat GPT with your
instructions and publish it yourself
this will lead to lesson planners for
tens of millions of middle schooler
users or full graphic designs from a
single taex prompt wow and look here is
where your gpts will live and from here
you can invoke the pier A system that
has access to 6,000 applications and can
control them it can look at your
calendar and summarize your day for you
find conflicts in your calendar and even
reach out to your friend and tell them
that you have some scholarly duties for
today and can't go so how hard is it to
build one of these this requires a great
deal of engineering and programming
knowledge right well not at all this is
in the spirit of Chad GPT and can be
done by anyone through natural language
yes we just add the instructions for a
startup helper bot what it is for and
what what it should do it gets a little
identity like these video game
characters from this previous paper it
also gave a name for itself and with the
dolly3 system built in it can also
create a profile picture for itself and
then it will give us some intelligent
questions on how it should behave just
think about it a year ago it required a
gigantic company to release such a
chatbot and now anyone can do it that is
incredible and now what well we can
upload some transcripts from previous
lectures of Sam Alman and then the bot
is ready for some questions remember
this has the knowledge of gp4 which is
an incredible body of knowledge plus
fine- tuned with the lectures and let's
see oh yes the answers certainly sound
like Sam Alman now press publish and
there we go perhaps a two-minute papers
bot would also be fun to interact with
and later this year an entire GPT store
will also be published this might be the
App Store of AI apps incredible perhaps
a historic moment in AI research I am so
happy to be able to share this moment
with you fellow Scholars and if I
understood correctly you will be able to
earn money with it so you can create
your own little doggy hotline and
perhaps even make a living out of it and
all this is open for all of us at the
end of the keynote there was a request
through voice to give a $500 credit for
all of the attendees of the conference
and then this happened so where is all
this GPT thing going well consider this
CH GPT has 100 million weekly active
users 92% of Fortune 500 companies
already use it it is now part of our
Lives it is everywhere from paper to
this in just a couple years Insanity now
there are also lots of recent startups
that are thin rappers thin layers over
GPT for instance a single programmer
could build this doggy hotline with a
few software tools and now the pace of
innovation is so quick that essentially
you can create these rappers through
open AI just think about it now one more
thing to consider a paper called
instruct GPT appeared in 2022 January
this was perhaps a predecessor of CAD
GPT and of course there is a two-minute
papers video on that it could do some
things but nothing too crazy with
today's eyes and wow we are
approximately 1 and A2 years later and
look at all these improvements and GPT
learned to see listen hear and speak GPT
4 Turbo appeared Dolly 3 dropped I have
to be honest with you fellow Scholars
this does not feel like one and a half
years to me this feels like a decade of
research to me this was a paper not so
long ago and now one and a half years
later it is absolutely everywhere people
are already using it to create an AI
commentator for League of Legends
matches an online battle arena game or
you can even Chuck a paper in there and
talk to it wow so here make sure to
invoke the first law of papers the first
law of papers says that research is a
process do not look at where we are look
at where we will be two more papers down
the line now we were not the first to
report on this and I hope that the
additional context was worth with
waiting a little and if you feel that it
was consider subscribing and hitting the
Bell icon thanks so much what a time to
be alive we are sponsored by weights and
biases experiment tracking model
evaluation and production monitoring for
your deep learning products and llm apps
it is the best everyone is using it try
it out now at wb. me/ papers or click
the link Link in the description below